author Tallahassee coats push the issue
of pavements to descendants of slaves
into a larger national discussion with
his landmark 2014 essay the case for
reparations that conversation continues
in institutions across the country
georgetown students recently voted to
pay money to the descendants of slaves
sold by the university and in january
fifty US representatives co-sponsored a
house built a study rate reparations and
Democratic presidential candidates are
also raising the issue China haci Coates
is here only on CBS this morning to
discuss hello Donna ha see listen I
remember that masterpiece' article in
the Atlantic magazine we all remember it
was seven pages sixteen thousand rolls
sixteen thousand words at the time there
were a lot of eye rolls about like what
is he talking about that was then this
is now and now five years later that
conversation continues did you think
that this story would have legs and what
do you make of all the discussion first
of all absolutely not I did not I think
you know I did quite a few interviews
around the time and I viewed this and
some except though you had as a
generational struggle when you're a
writer you are fortunate if anybody pays
attention to anything you do yeah so you
have to write out of you know some sort
of deep-seated beliefs I'm shocked to
see this continue on now in the
beginning even you weren't in favor of
reparations because people think it
means now we're supposed to play pay
every black person money because of what
happened in slavery yeah I mean exactly
and it's possible that you should do
that but you know we haven't gotten
clear on what exactly the process of
reparations it's not what you're saying
well I mean my basic you know argument
in a piece that I made was that the
relationship between african-americans
in this country and abroad a country for
most of our history has been one of
extraction taking resources out of the
community to profit other people at a
period of enslavement obviously for 250
years the period of Jim Crow when you
had basically a system of serfdom in the
South the period when black people could
not vote meaning that resources or taxes
taken out of their community it had no
ability to determine what was done with
that the period of
of the New Deal and FHA loans when we
basically built our modern middle-class
that black people were actually cut out
of even as they contributed to the
system that explains to a large extent
as far as I was concerned when I wrote
the article the twenty to one wealth gap
that that divides black and white
America and so I basically became
convinced that there was no other policy
beyond reparations that can handle that
and your argument is it comes right up
to the front door today this is not in
the past that this legacy is alive and
part of our culture now very much so
and I intentionally wrote the article
the way I did because I was very aware
that often what people say about
reparations is well slavery was a long
time ago you know she was dead it's not
affecting anything today and so it's
very important me that I start with
somebody who was alive and who was in
you know in the present and part of a
phenomenon that you know you could see
throughout you know many of American
cities let me ask you about the question
the pace of change you said this is a
generational question so give me your
sense of how fast the conversation needs
to take place because it obviously needs
pushing and pressure for immediate
action but on the other hand as you say
you can move too fast yeah I you know as
I said in the piece you know and this is
still where I am the day I think the
probably next step is HR 40 which is the
bill that Sheila jackson-lee now has was
pushed for years by John Conyers to
convene a study on exactly what happened
studying you know the period of white
supremacy and enslavement in this
country and you know the possible means
by which reparations could happen I
think that's extremely extremely
important because a I think we need to
hear from African American communities
about how they feel you know any sort of
reparations should be met I think this
country has not gone through a process
of educating itself you know on what you
know I really understand the falsity yes
yes yes and I think that's a really
really I think we are not talking about
a bribery payment but because of what
you're talking about it's actually
become a livewire issue on the campaign
trail right now the presidential
candidates but you pressed a President
Obama at the time on this idea and he
was very skeptical said he did was yeah
yeah and obviously I actually was
shocked he even said it was feel like he
even gave credence to your radical
portion of it but politically possible
now I mean has the pace of change been
actually that quick who knows
I mean who knows what's what's
politically possible until until it
happened you know I was one of these
people who did not think a black
president was politically possible there
were large swathes of Americans you know
who I know who didn't think Donald Trump
was possible who knows who knows well at
the very least you certainly opened up a
conversation that people were really
talking about and taking very seriously
today I encourage everyone to go back
and read that article again it's a very
long read it's a long race it's not you
know a lot you learn a lot and hope for
writers who toil always good to see you
Tom thank you guys